so as I was saying a second ago so you
decided to produce your producer on this
you're you're one of the actors and you
co-wrote it yes was there anything you
could have done that you didn't do
catering but there would be a lot of
dead bodies on my watch you know I think
that you know I was more of a backseat
producer I'm not like PGA on this thing
because it was more about it was my idea
to get a guy to bring David in to kind
of get this thing going and pitched the
whole thing and then get the team
together and then once the
pre-production started I was in I was in
post four boy I raised so I started to
get very hands-off at that point and
then just eat a lot of burritos to get
ready for the shoot and grow my beard
right so it's basically a great
pre-production for you yeah yeah a
double breakfast double lunch double
dinner right it was amazing uh one of
the things I'm this movie
first of all Congrats on the movie I was
I really really dug this film one of the
things that it has a big action set
piece in the third act and a lot of
these films always have the leader
giving speech to their troops I'm
curious about writing that speech
because you're compete you're sort of
you know what I mean there's every like
you have all these different films that
have that speech and I'm just curious
what was it like writing that and did
you put a lot of added pressure on that
speech yeah it was almost like the
pressure that was there about the the
pre battle speech actually took the
pressure off to kind of not to feel like
we had to reach for something just you
know we had chosen not to use a single
word of Shakespeare even though the
launching pad was my love of those three
players and having done them and you
can't compete with Crispin's day you
know some Crispin's Day speech to
inspire the troops and you know in a way
what's there is something very kind of
improvised and messy and I always think
those [ __ ] that I was thinking the
days before microphones how did everyone
even hear the speech like what was he
saying what do you say you know and I
think there's a certain uncertainty to
the way timmi launches into that that so
he leans in so hard to it
but there's a big under ability
underbelly of uncertainty and as I say
to him the night before if you can't
find a reason to inspire those people
then lie to them you know sure that's a
good advice
yeah when before filming began you look
at the schedule you look at everything
you have to do is there a day or two
that you're like this is gonna be a real
challenge look the whole thing except
our Mumbai sign a David at one point on
during the three wait to be shot the
Battle of Agincourt two and a half week
so I was like god I'm glad I'm not
directing this thing I just remember
thinking for the first time the
difference between writing a table on
your computer because we were bit off
different chunks of the story and wrote
and then shared homework this is how the
process of writing worked and I remember
thinking when we're on set I was like
wow we we write I write David and he
wrote himself into a situation where he
had to control hundreds of people in
Armour on a battlefield and I was like
how is he keeping us all together like I
just remember thinking I'm not made of
this stuff yet maybe or maybe never to
direct a movie of this nature completely
I am really looking forward to Barry
Jenkins Underground Railroad yeah and I
know you're playing someone not so good
yes what can you tease about the
character and the project well look it's
a what Barry's doing it is kind of epic
I mean it's it's a journey of one girl
who escapes and and knows is trying to
move north to freedom and I'm on her
tail but it's the character that I play
in the relationship that I have with -
so who's playing Cora is far more
complicated than just out-and-out sort
of abusive white man hates black person
relationship it's far more complex and
Barry is pulling out more than just sort
of skeleton he's like going into the
sinews and details of relationships in a
way that it on one hand it's magic
realism on the other hand it's a real
kind of history lesson as well but it's
a very human journey